non imposto non possono vedere non
passare mai visto benvenuti suoi the
styles oggi vita è stato sostituito da
berlino quindi io e merlino oggi
giocherebbe ad amon garsed per la prima
volta di no allora come praticamente io
giocherò separata e quindi potrebbe
succedere che io sono l'imposta ora che
è vitale l'impostore note volete che
giochiamo da mong nella vita reale
lasciato un bel mi piace mi sentissi
mila mi piace giocheremo da mondo nella
vita reale era iniziata mi dà ok lievito
trono partiti ho condiviso il codice su
instagram quindi siete tutti i miei
followers può quindi vogliamo vedere se
qualcuno di voi sa impostare sei mio
generata superstrada giocare assieme a
voi sicuramente se sarò io un impostore
di sentire il coro che mina uccide
salutare troppo iniziamo di the prodigy
vitale oddio di comite passare troppo
divertente
ok siamo in dieci paesi
ti amo da morire che carini però di
guardare herbert dare ok poi ha guardato
si stima che perfetto che iniziamo un
palo ora andiamo a fare le tasche perché
mi state seguendo stiano vedere se sei
per impostare il gioco
ciao trattato
dove vediamo inizia non è perché era
vicino a medici si stava la bravissima
di olivi qualche sospetto
l'ho trovato nel corridoio vicino alla
elettronica italiana con me grazie vabbè
allora tipo il voto dai signori pure lo
schifo non c'è nessuno però sospetto io
ho visto il bianco e anita è vero non è
possibile che hanno visto nel senso che
non sei tu ok anno po di tutti cercherò
però qualcuno ha votato per sé sono i
volti anonimi quindi non si deve vedere
esattamente che restate frequenza si
chiamava allora dovrebbe fare qualche
passo perché io lo so cosa devo fare
no non mi seguite perché tutti io sto da
solo di essere benissimo io ma quanti
siete
ma che cosa devo fare e sottomettere
allora vediamo chi è che l'ha riportato
ho sentito il suono mi aspetto scrivo
non votate v
io ho avuto la vita ti vogliamo bene ed
io modalità
o no
ma pacchetto renzi che voglia fare
l'impostore mannaggia non sono
sopravvissuta volta da importare non
sapevo cosa dovevo fare
si scherza si scherza
per la prima volta che giocano bene
siamo già in dieci quindi direi che
potevamo creare speriamo che questa
volta vada meglio
ok si parte vediamo non imposto possono
vedere l'occasione è visto tutti
e allora vediamo vediamo
[Musica]
ho sentito un rumore chi è qualcuno di
sospetto è sempre colpa della vita io
voto e mettono così
il bianco mi ha scoperto di nuovo perché
ho cambiato colore e questo qualcuno no
mi dispiace ma marrone o verso già
iniziato
ok ma che bello possa fare levitas più
tranche questa cosa o urgenti che delle
foglie
va beh cos'altro dobbiamo fare ora sono
molto più tranquilla devo dire che non
mi piace per niente 6 impostore o no
hanno già ucciso qualcuno
chi il verde acqua potrebbe anche essere
il nero visto che il nero ha incolpato
il verde acqua mi stava seguendo quindi
sarebbe il grade
ok ho votato dice io non lo sono io dico
dove era unito
mettila non sai ora presta a riportare
hanno tutti votato il celeste verde
acqua vediamo sera davvero l'impostore
store ha accusato un accusato il nero ma
sicuramente in nero è l'impostore perché
in nero accusate per teatro e qua forse
vediamo comunque troppo divertente
giocare con voi per i followers è molto
più divertente giocare con voi che con
persone sconosciute
[Musica]
un'altra tasca
qualcuno ha chiamato l'emergency meeting
il nero allora io ero convita alle dice
no beh in effetti il nero era sospetto
il nero accusato il verde acqua prima
quindi potrebbe benissimo essere lì nero
perversa del nero dice vediamo abbiamo
buttato un uomo col culo votato me io
che c'entro
mi dispiace allora idioma sta facendo
delle tasche con me quindi non è
sospetto il viola direi mai completato
le tasche
ora ma fabbrica avviluppate quantità
settimana ma vuoi dire vuitton è imposta
è male ma con un futuro che succede che
succede che sta succedendo per salvare
il reattore
ok ok siamo salvi
abbiamo quasi finito le tasse quindi
forse l'impostore perderà anche perché
non è stato ucciso nessuno finora non è
stato sconfitto come dice non è stato
ucciso nessuno esce subito il report
io ho votato vitale perché vitale dice
perché è un posto ha fretta questa cosa
io ero convita grazie non c'è nessun
sospetto chi votiamo qualche non sarebbe
però difetta
io non lo so io queste sospettare ai
quasi di anita nord
forse il verde disco verde
ok votiamo il verde il verde sospetto
dovere il verde il verde ha lasciato il
gioco quindi non era lei polpo plant
dice io posso contare sanità è bravo è
il vero deciso dal gioco quindi dobbiamo
votare nuovamente voto moonwalker
paris parità chi sarà l'impostore chi
starà o no
abbiamo subito al sodo il reattore
proporre rottura allora si avrà che
moonwalker mi stanno servendo e il rosa
è quasi sono tutti non sono atti che
sarà l'impostore sono tutti qua salvare
il reattore mentre l'impostore non
vorrebbe salvare il reattore 15 le palle
cosa mi entrano non fosse il rosso mi
stava seguendo scoperto dov'è finito ah
no è ancora lì ho trovato un corpo
chi l'ha trovando io e dov'era come che
l'hai trovato subito questo corpo perché
sto andando verso fare una task
nel nell'electric moonwalker dice il
giallo secondo me all intera con me
trovato un corpo vitale sospetto perché
sospetto
non lo so mi sembra che fai aziende in
modo un po strano io ho l'animo dato che
ci credo io voto anita ma no ma nessuno
riesce perché tutti e quattro abbiamo
votato sarà tra queste quattro persone
1 il reattore dobbiamo andare subito a
sistemarlo siamo in tre a chi manca ma
con una persona qui
noi siamo tutti e quattro
eccoli m chi sarà l'impostore di chi
manca abbiamo quindi qualcuno ha fatto
finta di un'idea
seguirò qualcuno di voi neanche questa
che seguendo mi devo fermare
vediamo cosa combina ancora che vuoi da
me io sto facendo del mio tusk anche
questo fra e un po fumetto perché stava
guardando qua mi ha chiamato io non è la
canzone meno male che ho beccato davi
far vincere le unità no votate vitale
news e anita drive canonical e vediamo
ok allora vitale non l'ha buttato fuori
sistema funziona un po male ma questo
giocheremo assieme allora per fortuna
siamo più mail più facile perché mi
viene l'ansia mette in dieci è entrato
qualcun altro non quello che si chiama i
love jones
andiamo subito a fare nelle nostre
tasche e questo è piaciuto a creta a
moon walk for seno prima nuove e vitale
che ha già fatto pratica ed è molto più
bravo allora prima 11 ferroso e stato
ucciso a mad men arancione usciva da
armi ma rita celi con i ragazzi datevi
non lo so chi votiamo chi che chi è che
di sera capi datemi lo dice il giallo
chi votiamo l'arancione come disse lo
sanno
non lo so non sono dice arancione giallo
settando incolpando a vicenda
hai votato dalla sola
a me non è lui votato ma non sono vi
prego da scoprire ma adesso si turava il
sole vediamo video tutti arancione hanno
votato all'unanimità
vediamo d'impostare chi è questa partita
è stata facilissima l'abbiamo subito
beccato essendo non devo vedere è visto
perché totti credo che poi gras sistemi
di andare insieme ad altre persone
io non sto facendo niente perché sto
facendo le tasse ok prima task fatta
grossa sta facendo la task quindi non è
sospetto dai che ci siamo quasi con
tutte le tasche
si no
ora sicuramente non era il bianco perché
abbiamo ora con me allora bianco
economica stai giocando con noi è meglio
di chi possa essere nella stanza io con
me mi ricordo il bianco ma non che corro
chi altro qualche sospetto dello scalo
qualche sospetto ha anche per non essere
troppo sospetto no è stato merlino
mi sa che questo cosa stiamo
ho visto qualcuno dice il rosso ma non
ricorda il colore
ok schifiamo il voto perché non c'è
nessun sospetto
ok forse di tutti bravi abbiamo saltato
tutti voi
questa è l'ultima partita quindi
dobbiamo impegnarci a trovare risposta
assolutamente impegnati touch
devo andare io sto facendo una task che
il verde stava facendole tasca con me
quindi sicuramente è un bianco continua
a seguirmi che 4 mentre i numeri
[Musica]
forse questa volta riusciamo a battere
l'impostore un'altra tac stiamo per
finire tac
c'è qualcuno che si chiama nessuno è già
sospetto e ri nome concordo un'altra
tasca completata mi sa che questa volta
perde l'impostore il bianco continua a
seguirmi in modo sospetto ma ho già
visto che non è l'impostore bianco forse
sospetta che sono io di sfruttare ci
siamo quasi con le tasche
e tutto così tranquilli stranamente
infatti si forse qualcuno che non è
molto pratico con fare l'impostore come
sta avvenendo il doppio forse a migliaia
a quest'ora stavo perché se non stavo
chiedendo nessuno allora non era il
verde sicuramente perché l'ha con noi
quindi potrebbe essere celeste o nero
dove era il verde con te quando ha visto
la prima volta mi stava seguendo quindi
rimane celeste e rosa che vieni che ti
seguivo perché ho finito le tasche non
si ha l'intenzione promosso anni non
finite anche io dice lorenzo ne ignora
la telecamera trovato il cadavere in
electrical
6 sospetto senette i reds già espulsa
l'altra volta è per oggi resta e rosa
sono spesso il mio voto rosa e va bene
votiamo rotta tutti quanti noi chiamano
vediamo causa di impostare ora salutiamo
il pollo e grazie per le belle
le partite
si basano proprio partita dei nostri
primi sei stato bellissimo
vedo troppo bello giocare con voi
l'abbiamo capito già ritorno del
cavallino non posso che dare un pò fare
l'informatore c'è un piazzato troppo
bella zucchero assieme sulla rete che
giochiamo ancora assieme a voi magari su
una live su you tube lasciato un bel mi
piace scrivere su tutte le vostre
richieste quale i commenti ora vi
lasciamo quattro linee su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video licata
su quella che preferite